this episode is brought to you by
givewell.org go to givewell.org and
enter real science at checkout to have
your donation matched up to 100 dollars
in the Pacific Ocean is a region that's
been almost impossible to study a region
so dangerous for many years scientists
didn't dare Venture there a place with
nearly continuous volcanic eruptions
kovachi volcano in the Solomon Islands
is one of the most active underwater
volcanoes in the world
it sits just 20 meters below the surface
and its base lies on the sea floor at a
depth of 1.2 kilometers Beyond this
little was known about this volcano for
the centuries it's been known to exist
that is until 2015 when a rare role in
volcanic activity allowed researchers to
get close to its active crater and
flanks for the first time
using a combination of underwater
cameras recording devices and scuba
divers the team collected a huge amount
of information even though it meant
taking a few risks although the volcano
wasn't actively erupting gas still
bubbled wildly from around the rim which
could cause caustic Burns if the divers
got too close the team had to listen
carefully to the water for The Telltale
Rumble that comes along with eruptions
just in case kavachi suddenly Unleashed
its Fury once more
but what they found was worth the danger
not only did they get bacterial and rock
samples but their baited cameras also
captured some incredible sights there
were zooplankton and larvae as the
scientists expected but also something
completely surprising
schools of fish like Bluefin trivali and
Snapper silky sharks and hammerhead
sharks were all seen inside the crater
the water temperature above the crater
was more than 13 degrees Celsius higher
than the surrounding ocean growing as
warm as 29 degrees Celsius what's more
the hydrothermal vents were still
releasing concentrated amounts of carbon
dioxide and sulfur dioxide which makes
the water much more acidic than normal
and yet this vast array of life forms
was still living in and around the mouth
of the volcano how are these creatures
all surviving such an inhospitable
environment and what can they tell us
about the future of our oceans
kavachi is a fascinating example of
Submarine volcanoes but it's only a tiny
window into a vast underwater realm of
Earth's 1500 active volcanoes the vast
majority are found in the ocean
some are the result of plate tectonics
plates pulling apart or smashing into
each other
other volcanoes come from hot spots
which form not from tectonic plates but
from abnormally hot areas of magma that
burst through and erupting volcanoes are
only a small part of the geothermal
activity happening on the sea floor
there are also hydrothermal vents which
form when water seeps into the broken
crust gets superheated up to 400 degrees
Celsius and shoots back into the ocean
filled with chemicals and minerals cold
seeps occur in similarly volcanic places
but the water doesn't heat up instead
sulfide methane hydrogen and hydrocarbon
Rich fluids leak into the ocean often
for longer than hydrothermal vents and
then there are the mega plumes which are
like hydrothermal vents on steroids
these brief but enormous bursts of hot
mineral-rich water are still baffling to
scientists because they're so hard to
observe but it's clear they have immense
consequences for surrounding ocean water
chemistry since a single megaplume can
discharge more than 100 cubic kilometers
of water in one go the equivalent of 40
million Olympic-sized swimming pools as
for kovachi it's located on the Pacific
tectonic plate only 30 kilometers
Northeast of the boundary with the
Australian plate it's released huge
quantities of steam Ash and glowing
bombs of lava on multiple occasions it's
even produced ephemeral Islands up to a
kilometer long over the course of its
explosive activity making it a very
dangerous object of study
and all of this volcanic activity in
Earth's oceans has had an enormous
impact on the sea floor
even long extinct volcanoes have left
traces on the underwater topography
the rugged hills and mountains created
by volcanic activity are called sea
mounts and they cover more than 28.8
million square kilometers an area larger
than any terrestrial habitat some of
them are in the deepest darkest parts of
the ocean While others come all the way
up to warm shallow Seas
scientists think around 45
000 seamounts exist all over the world
but we've explored fewer than 200 of
them in other words we've seen less than
one percent of what might be some of the
most unique habitats on our planet
while researchers stumbled upon the
first seamount back in the late 1800s it
wasn't until the 1970s that we first saw
hydrothermal vents and the bizarre
creatures living around them
in 1977 a team of 30 geochemists
geophysicists and Marine geologists came
together to study the Galapagos Rift no
marine biologists were included because
everyone assumed there would be no life
to see as they dropped their cameras
down 2500 meters below the surface the
researchers were surprised to see what
looked like signs of heat
and then to their shock something even
more unexpected came into view what
looked like alien life forms
foot long pale crabs red-headed two
worms the size of a full-grown human
clustered tightly around steaming
pillars
they had discovered hydrothermal vents
and the baffling ecosystem they support
from that point on scientists employed a
vast array of Technologies to continue
exploring these underwater geysers
there's the lost city hydrothermal field
in the Atlantic Ocean whose vent
structures grow as tall as the Leaning
Tower of Pisa and come from peridotite
Rock instead of balsaltic rock which
makes up most of the ocean floor this
means the chemicals coming out of the
vents around the lost city have a much
different composition than in other
locations and yet they still support
life
in fact scientists have found around 800
vent animal species and countless
microbial species with many more likely
to be discovered as we continue
exploring the deep ocean in addition to
the tube worms and crabs scientists
first saw in the 70s we now know there
are also giant mussels shrimp and
perhaps the most important organisms of
all microbes that survive alongside the
vents these microbes make up the entire
base of this strange food chain and they
do it in a place where there's no
sunlight at all for photosynthesis
instead the microbes convert inorganic
compounds like hydrogen gas sulfur
methane or iron into nutrients
this allows the microbes to thrive in
what would otherwise seem like hellish
environments and support many other
organisms as well
these microbes help explain the
surprising amount of life around kavachi
the researchers found bacteria related
to sulfurimonas which use chemosynthesis
on sulfur and carbon dioxide to produce
energy filter feeders like Krill and
clams can survive entirely on these
bacteria and those populations in turn
can support bigger fish and even sharks
it's all part of a vast volcano-based
food web and it happens all around the
ocean in different environments
take the giant red tipped tube worms for
example they have no mouths or digestive
tract instead relying on chemosynthetic
microbes hosted inside their body to
provide them with energy or there's the
vent shrimp which has a symbiotic
relationship with chemosynthetic
bacteria living in its Gill Chambers
it seems that the shrimp gets some kind
of nutrients from the bacteria and the
bacteria benefit from the shrimp being
able to get close to the vent systems
for the highest quantities of chemicals
are pouring out
and the life forms populating these
volcanic settings don't stop there
around kikum Jenny the most active
submarine volcano in the Lesser Antilles
of the Caribbean researchers found what
they believed to be the largest muscle
shell ever sampled one bathymagiolis
Boomerang measured 36.6 centimeters long
bigger than a foot long sub and near one
sea mount in Samoa a growing volcanic
cone named nafanua supports a thriving
population of eels around its Summit
vent
they feed on shrimp and seem capable of
surviving the hydrothermal emissions
even though other fish are killed by
them
and that is one very big problem with
all these volcanically active sites
there's a big risk of getting burned
poisoned or caught up in an explosion
[Music]
While most of the sea mounts around the
world are made from extinct volcanoes
there are still hundreds of active
volcanoes erupting on a regular basis
and when those eruptions happen they can
be disastrous for marine life
in 2011 for example a submarine volcano
near the island of el hieraro triggered
more than 10 000 earthquakes on land and
led to vast numbers of dead fish
floating on the ocean's surface
the ocean temperature increased nearly
19 degrees Celsius around the volcano
crater carbon dioxide caused the water
to be much more acidic and in some areas
the water was almost completely void of
dissolved oxygen
the debris created by the eruptions also
made the water much cloudier than normal
scientists found that the upper limit of
light penetration was a hundred meters
shallower than normal which can have a
big effect on Plankton communities and
other organisms living in the
mesopelagic
in other cases submarine volcanoes
unleashing gouts of lava have killed
deep sea fish which then float to the
surface sometimes teaching us about fish
we never knew existed but it means that
even those organisms that may be
benefiting from hydrothermal vents can
be killed if the volcanoes become more
eruptive and if there's enough volcanic
activity happening all at once it can
have profound consequences on ocean life
researchers point to the cinemanian
turonian event that happened around 90
million years ago and led to the
extinction of almost a third of marine
invertebrate species that sudden
collapse of ocean life is thought to be
largely the result of high levels of
hydrothermal activity making the ocean
too warm and too acidic
that said huge eruptions can have a
positive effect namely on phytoplankton
populations
just this year the largest submarine
eruption of the past Century occurred in
the South Pacific Ocean the hungatanga
volcano erupted in January and was so
massive that its plume of Ash reached 58
kilometers in altitude
the blast was so loud that it could be
heard in Alaska nearly 10 000 kilometers
away and it triggered a massive tsunami
wave
but that enormous eruption also
triggered a huge phytoplankton Bloom
that could be seen by satellites
scientists have hypothesized that these
oxygen-producing microbes had a sudden
boom because of the Ash and nutrients
released by the volcano
the effects of underwater volcanism are
clearly a mixed bag for ocean life which
raises the question of how the sharks
and fish swimming around kavachi are
able to deal with the chemical changes
to the water and the threat of another
eruption and it's still an open question
there are a lot of logistical challenges
for researchers trying to get out to
such remote locations let alone avoid
having an eruption occur right
underneath them but these issues are
well worth researching because they
could tell us a lot about how marine
life will respond to climate change as
more carbon dioxide enters the
atmosphere the oceans will become more
acidic affecting shell Builders and
other invertebrates
and as the temperatures rise Marine heat
waves are becoming more common and
threatening coral reefs as well as fish
so the better we understand how life
survives around hydrothermal vents and
underwater volcanoes the more we might
be able to do to protect threatened
species and help them adapt and maybe
we'll uncover a few more shark canoes
along the way my mission with these
videos is to inspire people to love the
natural world and to show that through
methodical science we can improve the
state of things
we all get a constant stream of the
everything is doomed narrative but I
actually think the opposite is true not
that terrible things aren't happening
but that we as a species are at last in
a position to make meaningful changes we
can learn how creatures react to climate
change and find ways to change policy
around that
we can learn how to create more
sustainable energy we can learn how to
protect ourselves from terrible diseases
with vaccines how to improve the lives
of children around the world by making
sure they have something as simple as
the right vitamins
but like with many things the science
only goes so far
how can we actually implement the
changes that need to happen
donating money is one way and we often
get pushed to donate to various causes
at this time of year rounding to the
nearest dollar at the grocery store etc
etc but there's always that sinking
feeling that whatever you just donated
gets swallowed up by bureaucracy and
never actually makes it to the cause you
intended to help it's hard to feel
confident in donations you could do a
ton of research to find the right
Charities figure out how effective they
are and how the charity will use the
money you give
but as a wise person once said ain't
nobody got time for that so to get
around this problem I used today's
sponsor
givewell.org there you'll find free
research and recommendations about the
Charities that can save or improve lives
the most per dollar
give well spends over 40 000 hours each
year researching charitable
organizations and only directs funding
to a few of the highest impact
evidence-backed opportunities they've
found
over a hundred thousand donors have used
givewell to donate more than one billion
dollars rigorous evidence suggests that
these donations will save over a hundred
and fifty thousand lives and improve the
lives of millions more
and on top of this givewell is
completely free to use it helps you
allocate tax deductible donations to the
charity you choose without taking a cut
I love that their top Charities right
now address malaria childhood vaccines
and vitamin deficiencies all topics
which I've researched the science of are
now areas where I can actually help make
a difference and the best part right now
is if you've never donated to givewell's
recommended Charities before you can
have your donation matched up to 100
before the end of the year or as long as
matching funds last and givewell is
completely transparent about how their
donations are spent and how their
decisions are made they even have a page
dedicated to the mistakes they've made
along the way
to claim your match go to givewell.org
and pick YouTube and enter real science
at checkout make sure they know that you
heard about givewell from real science
to get your donation matched and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now you should watch our
latest video about the insane biology of
sperm whales or watch real engineering's
latest video about helion and the new
way to achieve nuclear fusion